had a young woman come to me who wanted
some advice I had known her for a long
time she had been working at The Firm
for three years and she comes in and she
said you know I want some advice I'm
trying to figure out what I should do
you know next to make sure my career is
progressing the way it should and I said
okay before we do that you know just
tell me a couple of things how do you
like a job oh I love it you know what do
you like about it work is so incredibly
interesting every day I'm learning
there's Variety in what I'm doing I said
that's that's really great how do you
like your boss oh my God she's amazing
what a privilege for me to work for a
woman who's really taking an interest in
me as a young woman in the business what
about the people you're working with oh
it's an incredible group they become my
best friends we're out on the weekends
we're having a great time and I said
great you want my advice go back to
work what what do you mean next why does
there have to be something next you're
in an incredible place where
everything's working really well just
enjoy it because I guarantee it's not
always going to be that way if you know
if you wake up two-thirds of the time
and you're really happy with your job
you're really lucky and you're in a
really good place but I think there are
a lot of people that if they have a bad
day they start saying okay what am I
going to change and you know that's just
not what the journey is all about the
Fulfillment and the success in my mind
will come from the experiences not from
thinking that you've got it all figured
out